What is it like to be an Airbnb host?
From somebody who's been hosting for four years.
So, a little background on me.
I'm a traditional wife. Don't like using the word tried wife,
because that kinda comes across as something else,
but my husband's in the army,
I stay at home and raise our children.
I homeschool. And when we started doing Airbnb in our very first duplex,
it was just like the best thing that ever happened to us.
It changed our income.
It will be went from this long term running $900 per night, uh,
per side. Sorry,
per month. To getting $3,000 per side of our duplex per month.
So, like,
our income just jumped.
And it was a great thing that I could do while raising our children.
At the time, I only had two babies,
so, you know,
it was something I could do
and not have my babies in daycare,
which was a big thing for me.
So I just got off the phone with Airbnb.
For another disturbance at one of our listings,
and so I'm just frustrated right now.
Um, as I said,
I've been working with Airbnb for four years.
I guess I'm just gonna do some pros and cons
on running an Airbnb in your home.
So pro 1.
They pay good money. So compared to long term,
running, this makes you more money,
generally speaking. It doesn't mean you make more profit,
cause that just depends on your Overheads how much your mortgage is.
If you have a mortgage. If you're doing Airbnb. Arbitrage.
I hate that word.
If you're running from someone else and sub letting on Airbnb.
Or if you own your own home,
or 10 your RV. We use RVs,
and we use homes, and I also, um,
manage homes for other people.
So it really just depends on your overhead.
If you're gonna make the profit or not.
But it does pay more than long term, generally.
Pro number two, and this is my big one,
that you have control over your home.
With having a long term guest.
And you never know if they're gonna come back after 12 months.
To completely trashed house.
I've seen some really bad ones.
Roaches, dogs eating walls.
That's like the worst thing.
And then you just get the deposit back
when they've done like $20,000 worth of damage.
You get what, like two grand?
What's that gonna do?
And good luck chasing people down like that in court.
I've seen some really bad examples of that.
Now I'm gonna go to my cons,
and these have been stacking up lately,
so I just kinda feel like doing this video.
Um, I'm not saying that I'm quitting Airbnb.
Maybe I should do the other headline.
I'm quitting Airbnb. Biggest calm would be never having any time off.
It's kinda echo in here. Let's go somewhere else.
You never get any time off.
Now I'm hearing a dryer. Echo dryer.
What's better? I'm in my favourite listing right now
and this is my beautiful home.
You never get time off?
I know my working hours are very limited during the day,
so, like,
I only work two hours one day.
One day I work 10 hours. If I'm staging a listing,
I'm busting my ass working,
you know, the whole day and sleeping a very few hours,
but there's never time off.
I've literally had to message someone while I was in labour.
I've had to message someone when I was sitting next to my dying nephew.
He was dying of cancer just a few months ago,
and I had a guest messaging me about their inconvenience
at one of my homes as I'm watching him die of cancer.
Yes, we could use other people to help us with this.
We could have other people work with us and answer messages.
But overall, when you're running an Airbnb,
sometimes you're the only person that can answer that question.
Sometimes the person you have answering messages,
like my husband, my mother in law,
some of our employees, sometimes they just cannot answer that question.
So it's up to me to answer those questions.
The other negative part is Airbnb support.
Sometimes they can be really helpful,
but lately I've noticed that they're just giving people money back
when they're just complaining about something.
They can't even prove this.
If you know Airbnb, you know what I'm talking about.
When A guest complains about something,
they have to have evidence and proof to get to get a refund.
I'm coming into the fact that I'm there getting a refund within
like 30 minutes of making a complaint.
There's no evidence for the complaint.
They're not showing me evidence.
The guest never contacted me or message me,
and they're getting a full refund
they don't like the smell of the cleaning products that we used.
That's something that I had actually happened recently.
The guest complained that it smelled like cleaning products,
and we don't use a lot of smell and perfume.
They just smell like laundry detergent,
and that wasn't good for them.
And they got a full refund.
They got the refund
and I complained, and I also got my money back.
But it was just a whole situation that I wasn't prepared for
after four years of hosting.
This happened twice to me recently.
Um, so, yeah,
lack of support from Airbnb and their constant rule changing policies.
It's insane.
You feel like you have to fight every single day to get your money.
Now don't even get me started on Verbo.
I do like Verbo guests better.
They seem to vet there, then do better background checks.
My quality of Verbo guests are just so much better.
I've never in 4 years had an issue with a Verbo guest,
but Verbo as themselves or I don't like their software,
I don't like their app. Um,
you Click on a message. Oh,
you got a message from. From.
From Virgo and from a Virgo guest.
And I click on it, and it just, like,
just swirling, swirling, swirling.
It will not load.
And then within the five minutes I'm sitting there waiting,
I kinda lost interest. And then I swipe away,
and then I forgot that person even message me.
So overall, recently.
I've really been thinking about going back to long term renting only,
even though that's not what I suggest to anybody,
but I'm just burnt out. It's been four years.
I'm burnt out. I really enjoy the money.
I can't say I don't, but I'm burnt the fuck out.
This person is just tired.
I'm tired. I'm tired.
So now we're staying on Airbnb for now.
We're doing short term rentals only,
should I say. But I'm so close. What do you guys think?